what's the problem with politically
correct speech
the problem with politically correct
speech is that it attempts
to transform reality by redefining words
so i think we can all agree at the most
basic level that's what pc does
it it redefines all of our terms and in
so doing it hopes to redefine reality
itself
the problem for conservatives though is
that it lays a trap
whereby basically any way you react to
pc
strengthens pc and i use the term pc you
could also use the term wokism or cancel
culture but
part part of the issue is they change
all the words so we're talking about the
same broad phenomenon
obviously the one way conservatives can
react
to help pc along is just by giving in
right you just you use the new terms
you call bruce jenner she you whatever
you obliterate women's sports you
use all the kind of new jargon obviously
that gives them what they want
but then there's another group of
conservatives who say
no way i'm not going along with these
new standards you can't make me do it
i'm a free speech
absolutist right and i think a lot of us
have maybe used that kind of language in
the past
at various times but the problem here is
that the whole point of political
correctness
is to destroy the old standards right so
if you if you go along with that then
you're helping them to do that you're
destroying the old standards
but if you throw your hands in the air
and you say you know what i'm a free
speech absolutist
say whatever you want do whatever you
want i don't care i'm a purist right
you're also destroying the old standards
because now no one's so either way
pc gets what it's after and this is why
you know the phenomenon has has been in
our public consciousness probably about
30 years a little over 30 years or so
now it's been building for for more like
100 years
and it's why in that whole period of
time there is no shortage of
conservatives who said we're fighting
back against pc
we pc has gone too crazy donald trump
basically staked his
2016 campaign on this issue of political
correctness
but we keep losing i mean this is the
the first day of pride month where now
first graders in the united states i
don't know about the uk it's probably
the same there too though
in the united states first graders are
being taught transgender ideology and
kellogg's cereal is telling them to pick
their own pronouns
so obviously we haven't done a great job
pushing back against bc and i think the
reason is
no one is willing to stand up and offer
a substantive vision
to defend the old standards does that
make political correctness conservatives
fault then
yeah basically you know chesterton one
of your fellow countrymen
had a great line where he said it is the
job of the liberal
to go about making mistakes and it is
the job of the conservative to make sure
that they never get corrected and i
think that's basically what
conservatives have been doing the past
30 or so years
part of this i think is because we don't
want to
offend anybody we want to be very nice
we're sort of generally
content that's why we're conservative
right that's why if
if we were not content if we thought
everything had to be ripped down we
would we would be radicals so we don't
we don't want to be offensive
uh really and then the other issue is a
lot of
conservatives basically
share the liberals central premises and
this is especially true in the united
states
because in the united states there is a
robust
liberal tradition and i mean even the
classical sort of liberal tradition
um i think it's tocqueville who made the
observation that americans behave like
conservatives
but they talk like liberals so the
language of liberty and individual
rights is all you know it's throughout
all of our uh
founding era and throughout really all
of our history but we don't talk a whole
lot about tradition we don't talk a
whole lot about order we don't talk a
whole lot
about law and order even i mean donald
trump you know kind of brought this back
in at the end of his presidency
but it's it takes the the second
position
to this idea of emancipating yourself
from everything this individual autonomy
and uh you know ultimately i think that
the only logical conclusion of that
is going to be this transgender ideology
and you see it actually
with the development of political
correctness first you're trying to
liberate yourself from social mores from
traditions from
religion then you're trying to liberate
yourself from the family
structure you saw this a lot with second
wave feminism and then ultimately you're
trying to liberate yourself from nature
i mean this is this is why i know a lot
of people believe that transgenderism is
kind of the opposite of feminism right
one
says women are real and need to be
protected and transgenderism says women
aren't real is just
men can actually become women too but
it's kind of that logical consequence
of this radical liberation which i think
is kind of the theme
that defines western modernity the last
500 or so years
and i i think we're kind of on the fumes
of that you know we're
that that only lasts so long as you've
still got some
animating principle and tradition in
your society but goodness gracious it
seems like that's fallen down around us
so i
i just sort of think either we will
defend
old standards return to tradition if you
will
or or we're totally lost because the the
momentum of the radical left as
expressed in political correctness
is just so great and it's only been
accelerated
in recent years if you're stuck in this
catch-22 though and it's essentially
impossible or
the situation that you've laid out is
very difficult semantically
for conservatives not to fall into one
of a number of holes or anybody that
isn't a leftist
to not fall into one of these holes you
don't need to be a conservative to
disagree with some of the semantic and
lexical games that are being played
yeah what do you do
this is the hard lesson i know a lot of
a lot of people aren't going to want to
hear this especially conservatives
we need to embrace a just and prudent
censorship now people are going to tune
out they're going to say michael yeah
that's the word
that's the word i knew i i was always
suspicious of that knowles fella
you you know you're a censor you're an
authoritarian okay
from the very beginning of our country
there have been whole swaths of speech
that you cannot engage in that are not
defended by the first amendment or our
broader free speech
tradition that includes fraud you're not
allowed to engage in fraud
that includes obscenity increasingly you
are actually encouraged to engage in
that but still we have laws on the books
against it
from the very beginning we were we were
throwing pornographers in prison for
obscenity as recently as 2009
it wasn't that long ago and that was at
the federal level
uh you you're not protected from
sedition in certain forms uh going back
to the earliest days of the country all
the way well into the 20th century
uh you're there are whole swaths of
speech that you're really not allowed to
engage in and the argument for that by
the way
is that certain speech undermines speech
actually i'll go back to chesterton who
has another great line
i think he's the most quoted man in the
history of the world chesterton says
there's a thought that stops thought
and that is the only thought that ought
to be stopped there and
you see this especially in some of the
woke pc
educational ideologies now a critical
race theory is the one that's very
popular but all the kind of critical
theory
derivations come out and they say
there's no such thing as objective truth
if you teach a child that there is no
such thing as objective truth
first of all it's completely incoherent
because you're making a claim of
objective truth that there is no such
thing as objective truth but
you're also undermining their education
you're not expanding the curriculum
you're not opening their minds
you're undermining the whole purpose of
education
which is grounded in the existence of
objective truth and higher faculties of
reason and all these sorts of things
same thing with fraud right if you can
abuse your speech to commit fraud you've
undermined speech because now speech
cannot be relied on to to
convey any sort of truth if you rely on
free speech protections to defend
obscenity
you're undermining free speech because
obscenity and all
sorts of licentiousness undermine our
own freedom the founding fathers were
very clear about this
the even you know some of the greatest
liberal writers in the classical
liberal tradition will say you can't
abuse your liberty to the point of
licentiousness
because then you've undermined your
liberty and the example i use on this is
a heroin addict right right now there's
a big push to legalize all sorts of
drugs
you see that from the derelicts on the
right on the left rather but you also
see it from some
more libertarian types on the right and
they'll say we gotta legalize drugs
because uh it's an unjust infringement
of your personal liberty for the
government to say otherwise
i think most of us have known drug
addicts in our lives right think of the
heroin addict who according to the
modern definition of liberty is the
freest
man in the world he is may as long as
he's got a buck in his pocket
he can go buy whatever he wants he can
shoot up oh the pinnacle of liberty the
whole purpose of the united states right
i don't think so i think actually we all
know that man is a slave he's a slave to
his lower
base passions and appetites and this is
because
man uniquely has intellect and will
and we actually have two kinds of will
we have the lower will which is
when we want to just stuff our face with
cookies or drugs or booze or whatever
and then we've got a higher will and
very often they're in conflict st
paul writes about this he says the
things that i want to do i don't do
and the things that i don't want to do i
do and
we all know what this means you've got
you know you're you're at the bar and
there's a cute chick at the end of the
bar and you say i know i don't
don't michael uh uh don't but the lower
part of you it's the little devil on
your shoulder right he says go
go down there so we've got the lower
will we've got the
rational higher will and the rational
higher will is mediating between the
lower will and the divine will which is
this
divine logic of the universe and we have
an intellect to help sort it all out
and aristotle says this is what makes us
a political animal
you know more so than any of the
gregarious animals
and the the expression of that is in our
speech
right that we're you know we don't just
grunt we don't just holler increasingly
we do actually in us congress and
elsewhere
but you know in our best selves we are
speaking we're persuading one another
we're using these symbols of words to
communicate things about objective
reality
and the moment that you compromise that
the moment you say there is no truth to
convey or you say you're not permitted
to say these
these things and you're going to muzzle
everybody up we've just come out of a
year where we've literally been muzzled
by these masks everywhere
then you are cutting to the heart of
what it means to be human
and trying to liberate oneself
from from reality i think and i think
that's
the whole purpose of it and it's why the
left has been so focused on this sort of
thing and unfortunately
the whole time so many conservatives
will look at at pc and locus and they'll
say oh
it's just a distraction oh who cares who
cares
if you're going to call bruce jenner is
she or it's not
don't get hung up we ought to talk about
real things that matter like cutting
taxes a little bit more again
and you say well you know i like tax
cuts as much as the next guy
but if you lose our relationship to
reality if you lose the whole culture
then tax cuts in a buck 50 will get you
a cup of coffee thank you very much for
tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace